Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich glaube, ich verklage dich auf Unterlassung, dass du keine guten Witze mehr bei Lochbuch Netzpolitik machst.
Du mich auf Unterlassung? Ich äh verklage dich wegen geschäftsfähigen Verhalten wegen deiner schlechten Witze.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik hundertdreiundachtzig Euro Quelle für gute und schlechte Witze, um erfolgreich durch die Woche zu kommen. Trotz all des Leids, was da draußen immer wieder auf uns einprasselt, prasselt,
Prost.
Funktioniert? Ja, funktioniert, ja. Muss ich ein bisschen, ich höre mich so schlecht. Das ist auch Leid, das ist ein Leid hier immer äh in der.
Das ist ein ist ein gerichtetes Mikrofon, wenn du das in deine Nasenlöcher richtest, dann gibt's halt auch nur einen Nasenloch-Sound.
Ich spreche aber doch auch so ein bisschen durch die Nase immer.
Ja, das da kann ich jetzt auch nicht so viel dran machen. Das kann man auch mit der besten Technik nicht ausgleichen. Schade eigentlich. Ja, eigentlich schade. Äh.
Schade eigentlich. Ich will, ich fühle mich aber echt ein bisschen leise. Kannste, ja habe ich hier vielleicht den Kopfhörerverstärker zu.
Ich kann hier ein bisschen mehr Gain geben oder so.
Was? Wir brauchen Bass. Oh Scheiße, es war ein Sample.
Bass pass, pass. So Scheiße, es war ein Zettel. Gott, nicht, dass es jetzt irgendwie einer verklagt.
Ja, das wäre ärgerlich.
Dass wir wirklich bekloppt.
Aber wir können ja bald nicht mehr verklagt werden, weil die Störerhaftung wurde ja vielleicht abgeschafft.
Alles wird gut. Hat die Bundesregierung gesagt und wir wissen ja, wenn die Bundesregierung sagt, alles wird gut, dann wird auch immer alles gut.
Wir haben ja über das äh Thema letzte Woche schon ausführlich mit Volker äh gesprochen.
Von der digitalen Gesellschaft.
Genau. Ähm und äh jetzt ist dieser äh Gesetzesentwurf äh ist er jetzt schon entschieden? Ja,
entschieden worden, der Bundestag hat jetzt über diesen Störerhaftungsabschaffungsgesetzesentwurf äh entschieden,
jetzt feiern sich einerseits SPD und CDU und sagen, ja voll geil, Steuerstörerhaftung abgeschafft und wir kennen ja aber die Kritik äh der von der digitalen Gesellschaft.
Und die ist ja im Prinzip, dass der äh entscheidende Passos die Störerhaftung vollständig abzuschaffen gewesen wäre, dass man Unterlassungsklagen ebenfalls explizit untersagt,
der wurde aber gestrichen und wurde jetzt nur in der Begründung des Gesetzes angeführt, also hat gesagt, ja, hier Begründung, das und so, das wollen wir auch nicht. Der Passor steht aber eben nicht in dem Gesetz drin.
Die Begründung dafür war, dass ein Verbot von Unterlassungsklagen europarechtlich äh nicht möglich sei, dem Widersprechen,
einige Juristen,
Und wie gesagt, Volker haben wir ja ausführlich gehört, deswegen möchte ich heute mal äh zitieren jene, die diesen äh diese Gesetzesentscheidung nun,
Lobpreisen und äh feiern,
Da habe ich insbesondere den Niko Herting gefunden. Das ist ja Nico Herting ist glaube ich auch so ein IT-Rechtsanwalt,
Weiß gar nicht, was der genau beruflich macht. Ähm,
den äh öfter mal gesehen in dem so, ich glaube, ich war ein oder zweimal war der bei ähm.
Bei so ähm äh bei so Bundestagsanhörungen, wo ich auch war mit dabei.
Ja, der macht so Internetrecht.
Internetrecht, Zivilrecht, so Kram.
Buch geschrieben darüber. Was? Mhm. Internetrecht. Fünfte Auflage.
Guck mal, also ist ein Experte und äh der sagt, na ja, also die Sache war so. Ursprünglich gab es die Haftungsbefreiung und es gibt ja,
dieses Haftungsding,
störerhaftung und diese Unterlassungsgeschichte, Haftung ist ja jetzt weg und ursprünglich war es ja so, dass man gesagt hat, die Haftungsbefreiung bekommst du nur, wenn du einen Zugangsschutz, also mit anderen Worten einen Passwortschutz,
und eine Nutzererklärung äh Erklärung einforderst, in der der Nutzer sagt, ich werde nichts Schlechtes tun.
Weil man davon ja generell nicht ausgehen kann.
Genau, also nur wenn du deinen Anschluss durch ein Passwort schützt und zudem den Nutzer äh irgendwie ein Häkchen setzen lässt, dass er keine Rechtsverletzungen begehen wird. Nur dann genießt du die Haftungsbefreiung. Nun.
Man darf auch äh nicht über rote Ampeln gehen, bevor man nicht unterschrieben hat, dass man alle Leute auf.
Erstmal nicht über rote Ampeln geht.
Ja oder ist man also Leute umringt oder so.
Und äh jetzt sagt er.
Dieser Gesetzesentwurf Anbieter öffentlicher WLAN, Hotspots werden, Access Providern gleichgestellt. Das ist ja
die eigentliche Forderung
die ja auch die digitale Gesellschaft insbesondere ähm mit dem äh damals äh schon vor Jahren äh vorgeschlagenen Gesetzestext äh auch verlangt, aufgestellt hat,
und äh Hertingen sagt, na ja, das passiert ja jetzt, das wird jetzt gesetzlich klargestellt, da es bisher keine BGH-Entscheidung zum gewerblich betriebenen WLAN gibt,
Und jetzt sagt er nun.
Die zweite Forderung zu sagen, okay, wir wollen auch keine äh wir wollen auch nicht auf Unterlassung verklagbar sein. Ähm,
die kann auch gar nicht im im Gesetz stehen, weil so sagt jetzt Nico Herting, kein Gesetzgeber der Welt kann ein Unternehmen davor schützen, dass bei den Unternehmen Abmahnungen eingehen.
Und er sagt, ein Großteil der Abmahnung wird unberechtigt sein, ein Gang zum Anwalt hilft. Niko Herting ist Anwalt.
Ähm und sagt also ja okay, natürlich kannst du auf Unterlassung verklagt werden oder äh aber das kannst du natürlich eigentlich auch immer,
Und er führt dann an, als epirisches Beispiel, es gibt auch keine Unterlassungsurteile seit jeher gegen Access Provider,
Äh und denen sind ja jetzt WLAN-Betreiber gleichgestellt. Also äh,
Die Access Provider, wie jetzt deutsche Telekom oder so sehen sich seit zweitausendvier dem Risiko von Unterlassungsansprüchen ausgesetzt.
Und äh,
sagt dann auch selbstverständlich hat die Musikindustrie äh würde die sich ein Urteil wünschen, dass die Telekom zur Unterlassung der Verbreitung von Raubkopien verpflichtet, also,
Schönste Urteil wäre eben äh die Telekom hat es zu unterlassen, dass Leute über ihren Internetzugang äh raubkopieren runterladen können,
Also mit anderen Worten äh Sperrverpflichtungen für die deutsche Telekom oder eben äh Strafen.
Das würden die sich ja wünschen, aber ein solches Urteil gibt es trotz zahlreicher Angriffsversuche der Rechte-Industrie bis zum heutigen Tage nicht stellt. Nico Herting fest. Und
Er sagt, die Anforderung des äh Bundesgerichtshof an einen Unterlassungsanspruch sind äußerst hoch,
Also ist diese Latte kaum zu überspringen und genau deshalb hat es solche ähm Urteile bisher nicht gegeben.
So also die Gegenmeinung. Dass man also sagt, ja es es bleibt die Möglichkeit, dass man Unterlassungs,
Ansprüchen ausgesetzt ist. Diese werden aber im Zweifelsfall vor Gericht keinen Bestand haben und deshalb soll möge man sich doch dann eben auch,
Auf juristischem Wege äh die gegen äh solche zur Wehr setzen und dann wird alles gut.
Die These ist sozusagen dadurch, dass man jetzt die privaten WLAN-Anbieter den gewerblichen gleichstellt, sei ja alles gut, weil wenn's denen nicht passiert, dann passiert's den anderen jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Und da müsste ich mich jetzt, da müsste ich jetzt da kommen wir wieder auf dieses äh juristische Glatteis, äh weil ich ja immer äh den Begriff
gewerblich als äh kommerziell interpretiert habe in Vergangenheit öfters fehlerhaft und gewerblich eben auch einfach,
quasi also Freifunk wahrscheinlich, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe eben auch gewerblich ist, weil sie es eben regelmäßig äh weit verbreitet und in.
Noch ein bisschen anders, das war.
War das ein anderer Begriff.
Es war nicht gewerb.
Geschäftsmäßig.
Komme auf dieses Glatteis, deswegen halte ich mich jetzt hier an dem, an den, an der Argumentation von Nico Herting fest und gebe die mal so äh zu Protokoll und stelle dazu fest, dass ich eben,
da jetzt sicherlich nicht die die vollständige Kompetenz habe, aber ich glaube wenn,
Ist einerseits Juristen gibt, die vor Rechtsunsicherheit warnen und sagen, na ja, du bist weiterhin diesem Risiko ausgesetzt, wenn du das tust,
und andere Juristen sagen, ja das stimmt, aber das Risiko ist nicht so groß, dann heißt das eben aber natürlich trotzdem, dass es dieses Risiko gibt,
dann wird sich eben erst wahrscheinlich in in unheiligen Zukunft zeigen
welche Unterlassungsansprüche dann da erhoben werden und wie unter Umständen Gerichte darüber urteilen. Also denke ich, kann man als Fazit sagen, ja, das ist äh.
Weil ich würde jetzt sicherlich meinen Eltern noch nicht dazu raten, äh ihr WLAN jetzt offen zu machen, um äh die Nachbarschaft in,
nutzen dies das nutzen die zu bringen.
Ja, das wird jetzt sehr interessant sein, weil im Prinzip, so wie das halt jetzt ist,
bedeutet das der Gesetzgeber ist der Meinung, sie könnten das nicht explizit reinschreiben, aus welchen Begründungen auch immer, dann steht halt auch nicht drin, sprich,
In dem Moment, wo jemand, der im Prinzip jetzt als privater WLAN-Anbieter gilt,
treffe ja zum Beispiel Freifunk oder ähnliche Initiativen oder eben auch jeden, der da sein Zuhause mal sein WLAN-Public macht,
oder zumindest ein Gastzugang äh Public macht.
Da müsste man sozusagen mal abwarten, ob jetzt nicht doch so etwas, so eine Abmahnung mit äh Unterlassungsforderungen ähm eintrudelt,
Und dann muss es erstmal gerichtlich,
Geklärt werden und dann wird's halt spannend zu sehen, wie das Ganze läuft, ob das sozusagen von vornherein abgeschmettert wird. Ich habe jetzt den Berichten so ein bisschen auch herausgelesen, dass,
BGH, aber eigentlich der Meinung ist, dass sozusagen so das Niederschreiben der Bewegungsmotive in die Begründung des Gesetzes allein
das BGA BGH jetzt noch kein äh ausreichende Maßgabe ist und von daher ist es halt einfach Interpretationssache. Es wirkt so ein bisschen hilflos
ehrlich gesagt,
verstehe ich jetzt die Argumentation auch nicht und was das mit Europa zu tun hat und so. Europa steht ohnehin ja jetzt hier auch nochmal auf der Liste, weil ja nach wie vor,
Entscheidung des europäischen Gerichtshofs ansteht, da hatten wir ja schon drüber gesprochen, dass das quasi bisher noch auf dem Stand ist, dass der äh Generalanwalt sich halt geäußert hat und da eine Meinung vertreten hat,
und dann wird man halt sehen, inwiefern
Gericht ihm dann folgt oder nicht folgt, beziehungsweise wenn es ihm folgt, inwiefern das dann eben auch konkret formuliert begründet wird und was da äh sich daraus dann eben für Vorgaben, für die europäischen oder die EU-Nationen äh ergeben.
Dann fassen wir nochmal kurz zusammen, was ist denn jetzt alles gut geworden? Also es ist dieser Passusweg, nachdem du zumutbare Maßnahmen wie Passwort und Vorschaltseite haben musst mit dieser äh Rechteerklärung.
Also kein Captain Portal, kein Ki.
Das ist schon mal gut, weil das,
Natürlich, weil das in diesem Ausmaße zu einer allgemeinen Verbreitung von öffentlichen und freien WLAN-Zugängen beitragen wird,
und auch zu einer angenehmeren Nutzung, also das ist erstmal gut, es gibt nicht mehr den Grund, das zu tun
Das könnte, wenn man das jetzt mutig auslicht, eben zum Beispiel dazu führen, dass so was, weiß ich, wenn du in so einem Hotel bist, eben einfach mal verfluchtes WLAN hast
natürlich am Ende nicht, weil die, weil sie dann doch immer noch diese diese äh Hype äh randomisierten äh Nutzer, Kennwort äh Dinger reinwürgen äh um sicherzustellen, dass du auch nur drei Geräte in das Netz bringst und nicht viel,
Vielleicht also vielleicht sagen dann halt auch die vielleicht man könnte ihn jetzt zu dem Mut
raten das einfach mal sein zu lassen und einfach zu sagen komm hier Hotel mit WLAN, ne? Beim äh Waschbecken muss ich auch nicht äh äh irgendwie ein Passwort eingeben, bei der Toilette auch nicht. Und ich komme ja nun mal dahin, um irgendwie ein bisschen Infrastruktur zu haben. Bett kann ich auch einfach benutzen, wenn ich will.
Ähm es ist auch äh die Unterscheidung zwischen privaten und gewerblichen Anbietern gestrichen worden. Also es dieser Begriff gewerblich, auf dem ich da gerade noch rumgeritten bin, spielt eigentlich gar keine Rolle mehr,
Und äh es wurde auch gestrichen, dass ursprünglich äh die ursprünglich geplante Verschärfung der Haftung von Hosting Providers äh Providern, dass du also äh quasi ähm.
Als Cloudbetreiber äh für die Inhalte haftbar äh gemacht werden kannst, da wurde also auch zugunsten der,
Dieser Plattformanbieter, die ja irgendwie Gigabytes und Dateien pro Sekunde bekommen und weg und hin und her, deswegen gesagt wurde, herkommen, da seid ihr jetzt nicht.
Da wird jetzt also nicht ähm.
In einer Rechtsunsicherheit beim Betrieb von Clouddiensten, Wohnnutzer, Inhalte hoch und runterladen können. Ähm.
Aber da hat zu diesem Thema hat die äh große Koalition Koalition gesagt, das würden wir ja schon ganz gerne mal auf EU-Ebene jetzt irgendwie äh angehen und geklärt wissen.
Es bleibt eben dieser dieses Risiko mit dem,
mit der Abmahn mit der und mit dem Anspruch auf Unterlassung. Ja? Da wird man also jetzt,
gibt's jetzt unterschiedliche Einschätzungen unterschiedlicher
Juristen, die aber sich alle im Prinzip auf Zukunftsmusik beziehen, da müssen wir also mal schauen bis der erste
oder die erste freie WLAN-Anbieterin mit so einem Unterlassungsanschluss Anspruch überzogen wird und sich dann eben gegen,
zur Wehr setzen, wenn wir dann Glück haben, kriegen wir ja vielleicht irgend so eine Art Grundsatzurteil und dann hätten wir vielleicht echt mal irgendwann die Störerhaftung vom Tisch.
Ich denke, wir können diesen Tagesordnungspunkt unter positive Nachrichten abspeichern, weil zumindest gab es keinerlei Verschärfung.
Zumindest hat man uns das WLAN nicht verboten.
Ja, also es ist im Prinzip ist die Situation jetzt besser als vorher und sie ist auch an keinen erkennbaren Stellen,
Schlechter geworden und es ist nur nicht so viel so klar gesagt worden, wie wir es gerne gehabt hätten, aber es ist trotzdem noch nicht,
klar, ob's wirklich zu weiteren Problemen führt, ob sich Leute heute jetzt wirklich äh sozusagen schon motiviert fühlen, einfach mal WLANs aufzumachen, das sei mal dahingestellt. Ich glaube, das dauert noch ein bisschen,
ist eine Vertrauensebene eingezogen ist.
Ja
Dann gibt es ein schönes Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes. Ich hatte diesen dieser Rechtsstreit, der ging jetzt schon über viele Jahre. Ähm und zwar hatte.
Gibt es ein äh Musikproduzenten mit dem Namen Moses Pellham? Das ist glaube ich der, der Stefan Rat mal die Nase gebrochen hat. Ja, ja.
Echt?
Ja, das aber ich weiß nicht wie viele Jahre das jetzt schon her ist, aber der hat äh äh ich muss mal kurz gucken, Stefan, rav, mal gucken, hier die die allwissende Internet.
Neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig äh hat der äh Stefan Raab im Anschluss an eine Echopreisverleihung in der Nacht,
die Nase gebrochen, wenn ich das richtig Erinnerung hatte, der Rap hat den irgendwie verarscht ja hat dem das Nasenbein gebrochen, also so ein, sage ich mal,
hat jetzt nicht den Ruf eines besonders angenehmen äh und verträglichen Zeitgenossen.
Die haben ja auch irgendwie die Musik, die sehr oi, wie die machen, nur so komische Musik irgendwie, weil wie cool sie sind oder so und ähm.
Zehntausend Mark eingebracht.
Ja, die wird er bitter nötig gehabt haben. Dafür kriegst du Nasenbein noch nicht mal gerichtet.
Na ja, also und Moses Pennen war, also ist Musikproduzent,
und zwar von Sabrina Settl. Äh Sabrina Settler war ich war ich jetzt auch nicht darüber im Klaren, dass die überhaupt noch lebt, aber das ist eine auch so eine Aggres Aggressionsreparin, ne, die da irgendwie so sich irgendwie.
Der Angriff.
Aggressiv wie Aggressionen abbauen durch Sprechgesang und ähm in einem solchen, in einem Lied,
Ja, sagen wir mal, einer Veröffentlichung von äh Sabrina Setluhr äh unter dem Titel nur nur ich oder nur mich. Ähm ich hatte das gerade mal kurz angespielt. Äh ich kann nur mal hier kurz gucken.
Mir. Nur mir.
Ach ja genau, weil sie sind genau. Und da haben sie ein Sample drunter gelegt, was aus dem Kraftwerksong Metall auf Metall stammt
Metall auf Metall ist so ein eigentlich so ein rein schlagzeugartiges Ding. Und da haben sie halt das diesen Grund, dieses Grundsample, was man am Anfang hört äh.
Ich bin jetzt musikalisch nicht ausreichend gebildet, um zu sagen, ob das zwei oder vier Takte waren, die sie da gelubt haben und die liegen halt unter diesem gesamten Song.
Der Song hat als hat diesen Grund.
Ein Grundbiet von diesem Kraftwerksong, im Kraftwerkshong ändert sich der Beat natürlich, weil das im ähm das sind halt Musiker, die,
damit und in diesem Sabrina Settler, glaube ich, haben sie einfach nur dieses eine Stück genommen, die ganze Zeit wiederholt und dann hat sie da eben ihre Aggressionen drüber abgebaut und äh jetzt hat Kraftwerk gesagt, na ja, das finden wir eigentlich äh uncool,
ein Sample aus unserem schönen Song nehmt und noch nicht mal fragt, ob ihr's dürft. Wir hätten uns gewünscht
ihr wenigstens mal kurz euch ein okay einholt. Äh wir haben ja gar nicht unbedingt vor euch äh irgendwie mit mit äh ähm monetären Ansprüchen zu überziehen, aber so ohne zu fragen ist einfach nicht die feine Art und deswegen
klagen wir gegen euch jetzt vor allem Gerichten und die haben bereits zweimal vor dem Bundesgerichtshof.
Recht bekommen,
Und jetzt muss man sich fragen, was ist hier jetzt der der ähm was ist jetzt hier der wirklich zugrunde liegende Aspekt? Ähm.
Und das betrifft eben das Sampling
Ja, also du nimmst irgendwie ein Stück aus irgendeinem anderen Song und machst daraus was Neues. Und ich glaube äh auch Kraftwerk würde nach dem nach wenn sie den Song jemals zu Ende gehört haben äh sagen, dass dieser Song sicherlich jetzt nichts,
Nichts mehr mit ihrem ursprünglichen Song zu tun hat, sondern eben schon eine Genoin neue,
Kreation ist, die eine Schaffungshöhe überschritten hat, äh zu der dieses Sample, das aus ihrem Song genommen wurde, eben einen kleinen Beitrag,
leistet, der aber jetzt auch nicht unbedingt für das für diesen Song maßgeblich ist,
Das hätte der Pelhem wahrscheinlich auch noch äh mit ein bisschen Übung gleichmäßig auf die Trommel hauen können,
diesen Beat, ja? Und äh.
Entsprechend haben sie dann eine Verfassungsbeschwerde, nachdem sie da im X-Urteile X Niederlagen eingefahren haben, eine Verfassungsbeschwerde eingereicht, die eben.
Die Frage betrifft, inwieweit sich Musikschaffende bei der Übernahme von Ausschnitten aus fremden Tonträgern ähm gegenüber den Leistungsschutzbericht leistungsschutzrechtlichen Ansprüchen der Tonträgerhersteller,
auf eine Kunstfreiheit berufen können. Also ja äh.
Kraftwerk oder ihr Vertrieb oder ihr To-Trainer-Hersteller hat einen Leistungsschutzrechtlichen Anspruch an diesem Werk, aber ähm Moses Pellhem, so schwer es fällt und Sabrina Sädluhr,
haben, genießen Kunstfreiheit und im Rahmen dieser Kunstfreiheit, also,
Könnte das jetzt anlehnen an diese amerikanische Idee des Fair-Use? Ist eben eine gewisse eine gewisse Bedienung äh an an Fremdwerken in kleinen Kreise
oder im kleinen Ausmaß durchaus mal zu rechtfertigen, dass man sagt, okay, da kommt eine künstlerische Freiheit, die überschreitet die über
ist aber jetzt hier höher zu gewichten als der Anspruch den Kraftwerk an an diesen zwei Sekunden Trommeln hat.
Ja und das ist ein Novum.
Genau, denn das Urteil ist steht dieser künstlerischen äh Entfaltungsfreiheit äh dass ein Eingriff in das Ton äh Trägerherstellerrecht gegenüber dann,
aber die Einschränkung des Tonträgerherstellers in seinem Leistungsverwertungsrecht nur geringfügig ist.
Dann äh kann man das kann man hier zugunsten der künstlerischen Auseinandersetzung urteilen, sodass diese rechtlichen Ansprüche,
Hinter der künstlerischen freien Entfaltung,
Moses Pellham und Sabrina Setuhr zurückzutreten haben. So entschied der erste Senat des Bundesverfassungsgerichts und damit haben wir jetzt eigentlich in diesem Urheberrechtskram,
doch ich glaube ähm Leonard Dobesch nennt es auch so im Prinzip ein historisches Urteil, das eben hier eine,
mehr Rechte zum äh zum äh zum Remixen einräumt,
und Remix und Urheberrecht sind ja schon Themen mit den äh Leonard Dobusch sich ich weiß nicht seit wie vielen Jahren sehr im Detail auseinandersetzt, er betreibt auch dieses
Remix Museum hälter Vorträge drüber und alle diese Urheberrechts und insbesondere äh Remix Recht auf Remix Sachen, das sind alles immer Dinge.
Äh wo der Leonard Dobusch ähm sich engagiert. Und äh er sagt, das ist äh,
Schön, weil da mit dem bisher der bislang praktisch bedeutungslosen freien Benutzung nach Paragraph vierundzwanzig Urheberrecht ein neues Leben äh gegeben wurde und er freut sich da.
Und das ist glaube ich insgesamt, ja? Also,
wahrscheinlich ein sehr schönes Urteil, auch wenn es natürlich ein bisschen ärgerlich ist, dass ausgerechnet Kraftwerk
gegen ausgerechnet gegen äh Moses Pelham vom Bundesverfassungsgericht verloren haben. Aber da müssen wir jetzt durch, denn das Urteil ist erstmal,
ein gutes für uns und unsere Kultur.
Konkret steht da jetzt auch noch ein weiteres Urteil an, weil jetzt der BGH nochmal entscheiden muss darüber, auf,
sozusagen in Responset und in Abhängigkeit
Dieses Urteils kann das dann aber auch immer nochmal an den EuGH eskaliert werden. Also das ist zwar jetzt schon mal wegweisend, aber ob's das äh Ende vom Lied ist, huhu, das ähm wissen wir noch nicht.
Okay, aber das der BGH hatte ja ursprünglich ohnehin auch gegen Kraftwerke urteilt. Insofern äh vermute ich, dass sie unter vor dem Hintergrund dieses Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteils äh halb,
halbwegs klar kommen werden.
Aber okay. In in allen Fällen und ich bin äh.
In diesem, in.
Gesagt, dass sie in den anderen äh.
Nee, nee, äh Kraftwerk hatte. Oh nein, Kraftwerk hatte gewonnen, sorry. Sorry.
Das meinte ich doch. Das hat sie ja auch vorhin schon so äh gesagt. Und äh dementsprechend steht jetzt eigentlich.
Eine Revision des.
Ja, also man muss halt sehen, wie das BGH das jetzt sozusagen interpretiert und was da dann die konkrete äh Rechtssprechung äh daraus wird
Das wiederum kann dann aber von einer der beiden Parteien theoretisch eben auch nochmal auf äh EU-Ebene äh gehoben werden und ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck,
beide Parteien da unter Umständen sogar auch dazu bereit wären. Das wird dich ein bisschen.
Moses Pellham am Ende nicht Kraftwerk verkloppt, ist alles gut.
Vielleicht läuft's ja auch anders raus.
Ja, er wird auf jeden Fall den richtigen treffen.
Max Boses Pelben, nicht wahr.
Ey, der hat ich habe keine persönlichen Probleme mit dem und ich möchte auch keine mit ihm bekommen. Irgendwas so, also.
Die Nase sieht ja noch ganz gut aus. Deine.
Ja, seine weiß nicht. Ich weiß, also ich kann dieser Musik auch nichts abgewinnen, ne? Also es ist irgendwie so äh.
Ist ja in Ordnung, man kann ja machen, was man will. Also es ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Ich bin auch ähm gespannt, wie das so äh ausgeht, wie du schon meintest. Ich finde es auch ein bisschen schade,
dass ausgerechnet Kraftwerk,
das macht. Das liegt wahrscheinlich so mit unserer Verklärung äh dieser Band und derer Bedeutung so für die gesamte Digitalkultur ähm zusammen, aber na ja, so sind sie nun mal, ne? Ich meine, wenn man sich.
Du kennst ja sicherlich auch die Geschichte des Armen Breaks, oder?
Erzähl sie gerne.
Sagte nix. Der Armenbreak ist im Prinzip das berühmteste und erfolgreichste Sample der Welt.
Der Armenbreak ist ein Sample aus einem Stück, das heißt Armen Brother von einer weitgehend unbekannten Soulband The Winstons,
die das mal auf einer B Seite einer Single rausgebracht haben. Also es war halt ein anderer Song und dann äh,
B-Seite halt auch noch so ein Ding äh zum besten gegeben. Das ist halt so ein ganz nettes Lied, kann man sich anhören und dann gibt's halt so ein Break. Und dieser Break ist halt so ein Breakbeat, der,
im Prinzip die Vorlage ist für.
Breakbeat. Und äh sozusagen das das meistgenutzte äh Sample überhaupt in der gesamten äh Hip Hop äh Welt und in der elthronischen Musik. Jeder von uns hat diesen Break,
Hunderte und tausend und vielleicht sogar auch Millionen Male bereits gehört und das Besondere ist, die Winstons,
wahnsinnig irgendwann sozusagen der Popularität dieses geklauten Breaks natürlich bewusst, aber haben nie auch nur im Ansatz mal Anstalten gemacht, in irgendeiner Form, irgendein Urheberrecht äh.
Das hat wahrscheinlich Kraftwerk geärgert, ne, dass sie halt nicht so einen, dass sie halt nicht einen geilen Break haben, sondern irgendwie jetzt Moses Pellham und.
Ja gut für Breaks sind sie jetzt auch nicht so unbedingt so bekannt aber sie haben ja und das mag bei ihnen auch so ein bisschen die Triebfeder gewesen sein,
Sie haben ja schon epische äh Rhythmen und vor allem auch Melodien,
am Start. So, meine Kraftwerkssongs bestechen einfach durch ihre hohe Wiedererkennbarkeit auch einfachster Melodien. Und ich denke mal, das dürfte an der Stelle auch so eine der Triebfedern gewesen sein,
sie solche Ausschnitte gar nicht mal so sehr,
als, na ja, da hat jemand was von meinem Lied genommen, äh, interpretieren, sondern ich interpretiere das jetzt in Kraftwerk rein, ja, ohne sie äh näher zu kennen, ja, nicht verwandt, nicht verschwegert und äh ich war auch noch nie im Klinklangstudio,
sonst eigentlich auch fast keiner. Aber ich glaube, das ist sozusagen, sie sehen das so ein bisschen auch als ihre Ursuppe an.
Na ja. Gibt übrigens eine hervorragende Doku, den verlinke ich gleich nochmal dazu über diesen Armenbreak auf äh YouTube, wo diese ganze Story erzählt wird, das sollte man sich auf jeden Fall mal geben.
Ja und sonst gehen wir mal weg von äh der Kunst,
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das wirklich eine große Geschichte ist, aber.
Es gab einen Bericht bei The Worch über ein Bankräuber,
und dieser Bankräuber hat in den USA eine Bank ausgeraubt,
und wurde dann später aufgrund von Zeugenaussagen wiedererkannt, dann haben sie irgendwie seine äh Wohnung durchsucht und dort äh passende Waffen gefunden et cetera. Die Lage war halt irgendwie klar
er wohl dieser Bankräuber gewesen ist. Nun begab es sich so, dass diese Bank neun Monate vorher,
auch schon mal von jemanden einzeln ausgeraubt wurde und man hatte natürlich so ein bisschen die Vermutung, hm ob er denn das vielleicht auch schon gewesen ist, also sie wollten ihm quasi diesen zweiten,
Überfall dann äh auch noch nachweisen, wenn das denn gewesen ist.
Und da sie aber keine Zeugen hatten oder zumindest keine Zeugen, die in der Lage waren, handfeste Beweise zu liefern, die jetzt da äh eindeutige Schlüsse zugelassen haben,
hat sich äh ich weiß gar nicht, war das jetzt das FBI hier war immer nur von Ermittlern die Rede. Äh sag mal die Polizei
hat sich sozusagen dann unter anderem an AT und T gewandt, um mal so von seinem Telefon so ein bisschen Bewegungsdaten zu bekommen und die haben das wohl nicht ausgeschlossen, aber die waren auch zu unpräzise, um's wirklich zu belegen,
Na ja, aber die.
Aber die hatten ihn noch.
Wenn dich das richtig interpretiere, ja, es gab Daten, aber sie waren nicht präzise. Genug. Also das war sozusagen die Aussage auch von äh ATNT selber. Trotz alledem haben sie die angefordert und auch erhalten.
Gut, das waren jetzt neun Monate, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wann diese Anfrage war, also wie viel äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung an der Stelle da gegriffen hat,
war dann aber auch ähm ja gar nicht mal so sehr im Fokus. Und jetzt wird dieser Artikel so ein bisschen,
ungenau oder ich,
Bin mir nicht so sicher, ob ich das so scharf da aus der Schilderung herausgelesen habe, aber es wird quasi nahegelegt, dass man sich stattdessen äh seines Android-Telefons angenommen hat,
und nun auf irgendeinem Wege eine sogenannte Location History auf Deutsch Standortverlauf,
abgegrast hat, der einen sehr viel genaueres Bild gezeichnet hat und.
Auf der Basis wurde dann klar, dass dieses Telefon und mit ihm wahrscheinlich auch seinen Besitzer sich sehr wohl zum Zeitpunkt des Bankraubs dort,
befunden hat. Diese Location Historie ist ein Feature in Android, was im Prinzip,
auch als User Facing-Feature freigeschaltet wurde, seit Mitte letzten Jahres, dann heißt es nämlich Timeline und ist schon ein richtig tolles Feature. Du machst dann irgendwie Google Maps und sagst hier, zeig mir mal meine Timeline
Und auf einmal blättert das äh Telefon dir quasi alle Orte vor, die du so besucht hast. Und das Ganze ist so eine Art Extrakt aus dem eigentlichen
technischen Location Trail, das heißt da wird halt geguckt, hast du dich irgendwo ein bisschen länger aufgehalten und bist da nicht nur dran vorbeigefahren und dann wird das eben gemappt mit seiner mit so einer Place-Datenbank und dann wird da eben gesagt, okay, du warst ja so lange in dem Restaurant und dann hier äh in der Bank
Und na ja, das ist ein Feature,
was auf dem Telefon stattfindet. Und das Besondere ist, dass halt dieses Feature auch explizit mit deiner Google ID,
verknüpft wird, aber eben erst dann auch in der Cloud gespeichert wird, wenn du dem zugestimmt hast. Da lohnt sich mal äh in die Google-Account, Settings reinzugehen und zu schauen, ob eben dieser Standortverlauf dort auch äh eingeschaltet ist,
ausschalten kann man ihn nicht, man kann ihn irgendwie nur pausieren, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, was das bedeutet, wenn er schon Daten aufgelaufen sind und man pausiert dann, ob dann die Daten auch gelöscht werden. Man kann aber wohl in dieser Timeline.
Aus Google Maps heraus auch diesen Trail bearbeiten und explizit bestimmte
Daten oder Orte eben auch manuell löschen, müsste man aber gegebenenfalls auch, wenn man dort schon mehr Daten findet als einem das so lieb ist. Und man kann's halt auch freischalten, dass es in die Cloud gelegt wird, von daher und das da wurde jetzt auch in diesem Artikel nicht klar
Ob jetzt in diesem Fall die Daten tatsächlich in der Cloud lagen, ob die Daten von Google kamen oder ob man sich mit oder ohne Hilfe von Google einfach nur des Gerätes und dieses Trails, dieser Location-Historie bemächtigt hat,
Jetzt ist hier viel sehr viel ähm Fragezeichen äh mit drin,
Die Story kam mir so ein bisschen bekannt vor, weil äh vor ein paar Jahren gab's ja schon mal einen ähnlichen Aufreger über ein äh entsprechenden Trail auf dem iPhone.
Location Gate.
Location-Gate, was ich eigentlich mehr als Poamierfehler entpuppt hat und dann von äh Apple auch getilgt wurde,
Das Ziel war nämlich jetzt nicht so, wie jetzt bei diesem bei dieser Location-Historie von Google,
alles komplett soweit zurück, wie es nur irgendwie möglich ist, aufzuzeichnen. Also
Bestimmte Leute haben das irgendwie mal ausprobiert und haben festgestellt, dass irgendwie auf einmal die komplette Location Historie zurück bis zweitausendneun, wo sie irgendwie das erste Android-Telefon hatten, auf einmal vorfanden, so. Oh, da war ich überall. Das befand sich sozusagen,
auf diesem Telefon wurde eben bloß bisher noch nicht produziert,
Bei Apple war das ja ähnlich, dass äh man eben auch über einen sehr, sehr, sehr langen Zeitraum auf einmal diese Daten hatte, dazu befragt, sagte Apple ja,
Das war eigentlich ein Fehler. Da sind halt Daten nicht richtig gelöscht worden, denn äh sie halten zwar diese Daten vor, wollten das aber eben für einen sehr viel kürzeren Zeitraum haben. Da fragt man.
Moment App, also Apple hat das gemacht um seine ähm äh um seine äh Standorterkennung zu optimieren. Also du hast ja.
Darauf wollte ich gerade hinaus, dass äh äh wollte ja gerade sagen, warum gibt's überhaupt diesen äh diesen Trail, also warum gab's ihn da, warum gibt's ihn auch äh im Prinzip
schon seit Jahren Tag auf andere Telefon,
weil ja diese Telefone in hohem Maße auch davon abhängen, dass sie eine gute Location Ordnung haben. Erstens wollen die Leute das
zweitens ermöglicht das natürlich dann sehr viele Dienste, ne? Wir kennen das ja alle. Location Base Services, tolle Sache, nur die GPS-Empfänger, die halt dann in den Telefonen auftauchten, die waren natürlich auch extrem
ungenau, ne? Kennt man ja, GPS gerade in Städten flatter
mal gerne hin und her oder man hat auch gar keinen Empfang. Und deswegen haben die Hersteller früh angefangen, auch alle sichtbaren WLANs et cetera mit in diese Rechnung mit einfließen zu lassen und damit diese Standortdatenbank die Zentrale sich auch laufend verbessert
sollen eben diese Telefone auch dazu beitragen, das heißt, es gibt eine Übermittlung von diese
gesehenen WLANs der Telefone an die zentrale Datenbank.
Na, vielleicht nochmal kurz, also ich glaube, die GPS-Sensoren waren nicht nennenswert, ungenau, sondern nur langsam. Weil wenn du keine Vorannahmen, also wenn du einen GPS-Empfänger anmachst und der keine Vorannahmen über seine,
über seinem Ort äh dann weist der nicht nach welchen Satelliten er als erstes Ausschau halten muss und äh braucht ja irgendwie, weiß ich nicht,
Ich glaub ab sechs oder sowas kann er dann wirklich seine ähm.
Denn du musst, du musst vier Satelliten sehen, um wirklich eine gute Ortung zu haben.
Um eine vernünftige vier, ja.
Aber du musst halt auch in etwa eine Vorstellung davon haben, wo du in etwa bist, damit du dann auch.
Damit du weißt, nach welchem der vierundzwanzig Satelliten du jetzt Ausschau halten musst, welche du jetzt hier erwartest. Also brauchst ja.
Genau, das fließt alles in diese Brechnung rein.
Nicht schnell. Also äh GPS kann anfangs nicht schnell sagen, wo man ist. Dann aber, wenn es dann irgendwann du irgendwann mit den ganzen Satelliten deine Verbindungen hast, dann ist es natürlich sehr genau, aber nicht
zügig. Und der an, der der äh und GPS braucht, der auch braucht auch sehr,
Nennenswert Strom, den man gerne sparen möchte und deswegen machst du äh mach das Telefon nicht die ganze Zeit GPS, sondern es war für die ähm für die Mobiltelefonanbieter naheliegend zu sagen,
Überall stehen,
Towers rum, übrigens, ne, das Ursprühl, das erste iPhone hat das glaube ich nur anfangs nur auf der Basis von GSM-Funkmasten gemacht,
Die ursprüngliche Datenbasis wurde glaube ich damals sogar gesammelt mit den Google Street View Autos von Google und die haben einfach gesagt, wir nehmen stationäre Funksender, wie,
Ähm äh die Zell äh äh die also die Mobilfunkmasten,
die WLAN-Sender und machen quasi eine Karte.
Aus, welche Empfangsstärke, welches, welches WLAN-Signales haben wir an welchem Ort. Und äh,
Wie gesagt, sind dann ursprünglich, ich glaube, die erste Datensammlung in der Art war mit den Google Streetwears, da haben sie auch noch auf den Sack bekommen, weil sie das WLAN mitgeschnitten hatten, äh wie heißt nochmal dieses WLAN mit Snift-Tool, was man dann nimmt,
Tool, der Typ, der das geschrieben hatte, hat er auch diese Google Street View-Autos äh ausgestattet. Das war noch irgendwie ein ganz interessanter äh interessantes Ding damals,
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt dieses Telefon irgendwie, wenn du Google Maps aufmachst an deinem Telefon, dann,
Was ist als erstes macht ist es guckt nach den WLANs in seiner Umgebung und,
Entweder hat es dann eine lokale Datenbank und weiß, ach ey wenn dieses WLAN hier ist, dann bin ich bin ich zu Hause oder er weiß natürlich nicht, dass es zu Hause ist, aber dann bin ich an diesem Ort. Ähm oder es schickt die gesammelten WLANs, die so empfängt.
An die Cloud und sagt, gib mir doch mal eine grobe GPS-Position zurück, dann weiß ich wen, dann kriege ich hier schneller meinem Nutzer gesagt, wo wir sind.
Und Apple hat diese Daten gesammelt, weil diese die WLANs ändern sich ja, kommen neue hinzu, werden äh werden umbenannt oder sowas, wenn du das jetzt nicht aufgrund der Mac-Adresse machst und,
Apple hat dann diese Daten,
Einen Ausschnitt dieser riesigen Datenbank, die sie irgendwo haben, wo drin steht, folgender GPS-Location, folgende Signalstärke von folgenden WLANs. Ähm davon hatten sie natürlich die Orte, an denen du dich häufig aufhältst, äh,
in einem Cash drin und das war die Datei, äh die dann zu dem Location-Gate geführt hat, weil sie äh zu groß wurde,
Zu viele Einträge hatte und außerdem in den iPhone Backups war und du konntest dann eine Software auf der Mac,
ausführen, die diese Datei aus dem iPhone Backup angeschaut hat und dir visualisiert hat mit Punkten an den Orten.
Genau, da war ja Michael Kreil, auch gleich einer der ersten, der da schöne äh Karten draus gemacht hat, kurze Anmerkungen noch zu dem, was du gesagt hast, also mit dem GPS ist ging also es ist nicht nur dieses nicht schnell genug, sondern es ist halt auch teilweise nicht
du hast halt einfach nicht überall GPS, insbesondere in Gebäuden, äh ist halt das sozusagen einfach meistens keine Option
und das was halt frühzeitig aber schon Abhilfe geschafft hat, ist halt dieses sogenannte AGPS, also es ist jetzt GPS, wo dann eben in dem Moment, wo du zumindest eine Datenverbindung zu deinem Zelltower hast,
vom Zelthower selber gesagt wird, da wo du bist, solltest du eigentlich diese Satelliten jetzt sehen. Und damit
konnte sozusagen dieser äh da gibt's einen Namen für diese,
für diese erste, für diesen für diesen ersten Schritt, den man macht, bei mir ist gerade nicht drauf. Äh der wurde dadurch schon extrem viel schneller, aber es kann halt trotzdem sein, dass GPS nicht da ist. Und selbst wenn du eine GPS-Ordnung hast, ist hier halt einfach mal ein,
nur in Anführungsstrichen auf zehn Meter genau, sprich,
in der Stadt mit Reflektionen und so weiter, auch schnell kennen wir ja auch äh mal fünfzig oder hundert Meter und um eben das einfach zu verbessern, hat man wieder auch noch mit reingezogen. Also.
Und WLAN hat halt den Vorteil nochmal gegenüber den den Mobilfunknetzen, dass diese WLAN-Zeit wirklich nicht weit reichen,
Das heißt aus einfach aus der, also du kannst ja jetzt, ne, du machst um eine von mir aus um deine wenn du jetzt in so einer Wohnung wohnst, kannst du vielleicht noch draußen ja,
Je nachdem, wie hoch die Wohnung ist, so zehn, zwanzig Meter äh Radius ziehen, dann gibt's ja auch noch die Signalstärke, die du da mit reinziehen kannst. Da machst du in so einer Stadt wie Berlin, wo in jedem Haus irgendwie zwanzig WLANs oder vierzig WLANs sind, ähm brauchst du nur ein paar, um dich wirklich millimetergenau zu positionieren. Wenn du diese Datenbank hast
aber wir schweißen auch vollständig ab Tim. Wir schweifen ab, das ist nicht mehr feierlich. Wie kommen wir jetzt mit unserem GPS zur Bank.
Ich wollte ja nur sagen erstmal also.
Du wolltest erstmal erzählen, dass Apple nicht so schlimm ist wie Google.
Nein, ich habe nur gesagt, warum es überhaupt diese Trails gibt. So und das hat sich ja bei bei äh Apple gezeigt
in diesem Location geht, da war das sozusagen das erste Mal diese Thematisierung, wie funktioniert das eben? Das hast du ja eben wunderbar erklärt
Natürlich gibt es diese Logik auch von Anfang an auf Android-Telefonen
nur das Location ist, Refeature ist natürlich jetzt auf den Android-Telefon sehr viel mehr mit deiner ID vernetzt als das äh laut Apples Angaben äh bei iOS
Der Fall ist, trotz alledem ist das sozusagen eine Grundfunktion, die so ein Telefon hat. Ähm ja, es ist
dann auch, also es gibt dann auch noch äh einen Bericht von The Intersep, die ähm Dokumente zugespielt bekommen haben, dass eben
explizite Trainingdokumente gibt beim äh FBI
halt also tatsächlich daraufhin geschult werden, explizit diese Location-Historie von Android-Telefon, also da geht's jetzt auch ganz konkret um Android eben für sich nutzbar zu machen, in dem dann eben auch schon beklagt wird, dass es ja dann auch noch die Möglichkeit gibt für die User äh auch einzelne Einträge zu löschen. Da wissen sie wohl
Noch nicht wie sie dem Herr werden sollen unklar bleibt warum.
In welchem Maße Google jetzt hier,
dazu beigetragen hat, da haben wir halt wieder diesen alten Fall mit was darf oder was muss Google
wenn die Behörden anmarschiert kommen, liefern. Sie meinen halt, dass auch in den
Fällen wo diese National Security Geschichte aktiviert wird, wo es ja sozusagen mit maximaler Geheimhaltung, diesen Gagorders äh am Start ist
Meinen sie das selbst in den Fällen häufig, aber das sind halt jetzt so wirre Aussagen äh das noch nicht ausreicht, um eben Location Data auch zu präsentieren,
weil es halt meistens irgendwie natürlich so, wir wollen mal in die Box äh schauen und ähnliche Geschichten sind,
Gut, ist ähm ein Punkt, den man jetzt an der Stelle auch ein bisschen offen lassen sollen, wenn ihr aber ein Android-Telefon habt, solltet ihr unter Umständen zumindest mal checken, wie euer Setting ist.
Also vorm Bankraub äh Android Timeline.
Genau, vorher. Pausieren, pausier.
Danach wieder anmachen. Die äh sie.
Ich finde das ganz interessant, weil immer so, weil ich weiß, ich seit wie viel Jahren jetzt immer so irgendwie
Das Mobiltelefon als Ordnungswanze in ihrer Tasche. Wir alle haben eins. Und es ist immer so, wenn irgendwann kommt, blutet die das aus den Ohren, ne? Aber es ist halt nur leider echt so, ne? Das ist äh und es gibt dann immer auch so äh,
Finde das ganz interessant. Ähm jetzt gerade wieder gesehen, dass es äh ich glaube, das geht ja ursprünglich Aram Barthol. Ich weiß nicht, ob der das vor zehn Jahren gemacht hat oder so als Kunstaktion. Äh dieser Pharadation äh Taschen für,
Mobiltelefone, ne? Wo du sagen kannst, okay, wenn das da drin ist, hat es keinen Empfang mehr und das ist immer noch irgendwie so ein Ding, ne, das was du dann auf Workshops oder so siehst, wo dann Leute sagen so, jetzt
äh nähen wir eine paradäsche Tasche für unser Telefon. Edwards Norden hat noch irgendwie letztens gesagt, sie je nachdem, was dein Paranoia-Level ist, ne, nimm den Akku raus und tust in eine Feriday-Tasche und irgendjemand antwortet dann auf Twitter so. Ja, ich habe ein iPhone
Kann ich ja keinen Akku rausnehmen, ne?
Äh schöne Scherze. Ähm ja, weil also man sollte dann eben ähm wenn man jetzt wirklich ähm,
ne? Also wenn man wirklich nicht möchte, dass irgendwann einmal nachweisbar ist, dass man einen Ort war, dann ist das schon echt eine Herausforderung heutzutage. Also Telefon mitnehmen
grundsätzlich nicht empfohlen, aber da hast du halt auch noch die Überwachungskameras, die irgendwo an der an der Decke kleben und so. Es ist schon äh wirklich,
Glaube ich ziemlich schwierig.
Dich heute noch irgendwo an einen Ort zu bewegen ohne darüber eine digitale Spur zu hinterlassen.
Wollen wir bei Google?
Bleiben wir bei Google.
Ja, wir hatten ja äh Lokbodennetzpolitik berichtete.
Letzte Woche haben wir uns über den den Urheberrechtsstreit äh zwischen Google und Orical ähm unterhalten und man hat ja also
In den Kommentaren wurde auch angemerkt, dass wir wahrscheinlich da die gesamte Bedeutung und das Ausmaß und äh den Streit dieses äh Streit
Kernpunkt dieser gerichtlichen Auseinandersetzung nicht einhundert Prozent erfasst haben. Ähm, einer der
äh klarsten Kommentare dazu kam von Alex, äh der eben schrieb, na ja.
Also Alex hat das, hat diese Sache so ein bisschen äh besser verfolgt. Offenbar und sagte, der aktuelle Prozess findet doch nur statt, weil der zuständige äh Peelskord zuvor entschieden hat,
dass es eben doch ein Copyright of APIs gibt.
Anmerkung, das Gericht, vor dem der aktuelle Prozess läuft, hatte in zweitausendzwölf noch entschieden, dass das nicht der Fall sei,
Und jetzt geht es in, ging es in diesem Verfahren nur darum, ob die remplementierung der Java API durch Google,
Fair Use war oder nicht.
Und entsprechend sieht auch das äh Urteil aus. Äh in dem nämlich äh äh die,
die Geschworenen glaube ich oder was auch immer da, wie wer auch immer entschieden hat, äh die genau diese Frage beantwortet haben
fällt das, was Google da getan hat unter Fair-Use und das Häkchen ist bei ja und drüber steht noch der Hinweis, du musst eindeutig antworten und das wurde auch getan
Und ähm dass dieses Urteil spart also jetzt,
Google neun Milliarden Dollar Entschädigung und das Urteil heißt also Google hat mit Android die Rechte der Firma Orical an der eingekauften Programmiersprache Java,
nicht zumindest nicht so tiefgreifend und signifikant verletzt,
sie zu Schadenssatz, Schadensersatz verpflichtet werden. Es gibt jetzt gemischte Gefühle zu diesem Urteil, ne? Die einen sagen, na ja, also wenn ich äh eine auch wenn nicht irgendwas Open Source mache oder so, dann will ich ja auch, dass die Leute sich an die Lizenz halten
und ob da jetzt irgendwie tausend Zeilen Code kopiert wurden oder nicht und in kommerzielles Produkt eingebaut wurden,
Ich weiß es tatsächlich nicht genau zu beurteilen. Dieses dieses Thema,
Kann ich nicht genug zu sagen. Bin also da fehlt mir auch so ein bisschen die Emotion.
Ob ich Orical jetzt neun Milliarden gegönnt hätte, weiß ich nicht,
ob ich Google mal eine neun Milliarden Strafe für diesen Android Fuckup äh gegönnt hätte weiß also ja.
Ja, ich muss sagen, bei APIs. Das ist halt wieder so eine Sache mit der äh Schöpfungshöhe einer eines sogenannten geistigen Eigentums.
Und das ist ja ohnehin ein problematisches Feld.
APIs sind ja in gewisser Hinsicht so eine Art Festschreibung eines Entwicklungsstandes.
Du sagst halt, wenn du das benutzen willst, musst du dich so mir gegenüber verhalten. So und die die dahinter stehende Frage ist ja nun, ist sozusagen diese Dokumentation.
Dieses Verhaltens in sich eine eine schützenswerte, schöpferische Leistung.
Kann man jetzt so oder so argumentieren? Selbstverständlich,
Also ist das auf jeden Fall eine Leistung, weil auch ein gutes API hinzubekommen, heißt viel rumtesten und so weiter. Äh am Ende brauchst du natürlich Running Code,
Trotz alledem ist äh auch das selbst schon das Dokumentieren wahrscheinlich in gewisser Hinsicht schon eine Leistung nur.
Das dann sozusagen nicht kopierbar zu machen, halte ich halt einfach für schwierig, weil.
Wenn dem so sei, ja, hatten wir im Prinzip äh wieder pure Softwarepatent.
Das wird die Festschreibung von Monopolen
nur fördern und vor allem äh einen Hebel liefern, Konkurrenz auszuschließen, der dann einfach irgendwann auch nichts mehr mit eigener Leistung zu tun hat.
Also wer vielleicht auch mal wertvoll mal mit unseren Urheberrechts äh Juristenspezis das mal zu diskutieren. Ich habe
Kein Überblick, wie das überhaupt in Europa gehandhabt wird. Bisher sehe ich da nur diese ganzen Vorgehens äh Weisen in den USA.
Auf jeden Fall äh äh Google äh Oracle hat gesagt, ja nee, das ist Quatsch, was hier geurteilt wurde. Wir gehen in Berufung und äh Google äh sagt na ja, mit dem nächsten Android äh werden wir
die
durch große Teile der freien Javaimplementierung, Open J ersetzen, äh die ja äh unter GPL steht und dann äh haben wir den haben wir den Ärger in Zukunft nicht mehr.
Jetzt kommen wir zur Kurzmeldung.
Schö.
Ganz eine eine schöne Forschung äh von der äh freien Universität Amsterdam, die sagt, die haben sich die Flicker für die Kay genommen, das ist eine äh Fotodatenbank mit äh dreißigtausend Bildern und,
Dann haben sie per Crowdsourcing Beschreibungen des Bildinhaltes gesammelt. Ähm,
Crowdforcing, in dem Fall nicht nur von Freiwilligen, sondern sie haben ähm Helfer, die sie über Amazons, Minijob äh Plattform
McCanical Turk
äh angeheuert haben. Micanical Turk ist ja ein ein lustiger Begriff, also der mechanische Türke, eine ähm ich kenne mir ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wer dieser Begriff stammt, aber es ist im Prinzip die Idee, dass also, dass du ein,
dass für einen Menschen hast, der.
Eine Automatisierbare Aufgabe erfüllt und dadurch du den Eindruck hast, dass es irgendwie so ein Roboter ist, ne? Also kannst bei Amazon McCanical Turk eben Kleinstaufgaben äh,
Ähm erledigen lassen und und Menschen dafür bezahlen, die eben wenig Geld für äh,
einfache Arbeiten bekommen. Und ähm haben gesagt, schaut euch bitte diese Bilder an und ähm beschreibt, was da drin zu sehen ist. Dann haben sie für jedes dieser dreißigtausend Bilder jeweils fünf,
Beschreibungen gesammelt über McCanical äh Turk. Und da haben sie festgestellt, ähm dass sich in diesen Bildbeschreibungen, die ja dann,
in also so lernst, lernst du ja einer künstlichen Intelligenz, das Erkennen von Bildern
ihr einfach Bilder gibst und Bildbeschreibung und sagst, hier sieht man das, hier sieht man das, guck dir das an, merk dir's und versuch dir zu, versuch es zu erkennen. Äh der Rest, den Rest macht das neuronale Netz und äh fertig.
Man liefert die positive anhand dieser KI dann sich sozusagen trainieren kann.
Genau.
Jetzt haben sie gesagt, na ja, in diesen Beschreibungen steht zum Beispiel, das war irgendwie ein Mann und eine Frau zu sehen und die Beschreibung war, hier wird eine Arbeiterin von ihrem Chef,
ernst gemaßregelt. Dabei war in dem Bild überhaupt nicht erkennbar.
Was jetzt das Verhältnis äh der beiden ist ähm sie blickt hier jetzt in diesem Foto kurz zu Boden, aber ob er sie jetzt maßregelt oder tröstet, war halt nicht zu erkennen, aber er hat nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen Arbeitsklamotten an, also ne, aber ist
In dem Bild war das einfach nicht zu sehen äh und äh
oder das war halt eine klare Interpretation, die Menschen da geliefert haben, nämlich, dass die Frau selbstverständlich äh hier die äh die Untergebene ist, wenn der Mann mit ihr redet, der ist ja auch größer,
ja? Und äh da spiegeln sich eben dann in diesen einfachsten Bildbeschreibungen,
Stereotype, die Menschen über unsere Gesellschaft haben. Dieses Serie Type sind, ja? Ähm deshalb da, weil sie,
im größeren Teil der Fälle zutreffend sind. Das ist der Grund, warum wir Menschen Stereotypen haben, weil sie uns helfen, uns,
schnell zu orientieren und das haben diese Personen, die dieses Bild beurteilt haben auch. Wo gesagt, ah, wann habe ich, wo habe ich sowas schon mal gesehen? Ja, Klassiker, äh die Arbeiterin wird von ihrem Chef äh zur Sau gemacht, ja,
Wie gesagt, das war keine objektive Bildbeschreibung. Und war eben von Stereotypen geprägt. Anderes ähm.
Beispiel war, dass Leute ähm Dinge explizit erwähnen, die von ihrer allgemeinen Erwartung abweichen. Zum Beispiel,
Wenn sie ein weißes Baby sehen, sagen sie, da ist ein Baby zu sehen. Wenn sie ein dunkelhäutiges oder asiatisches Baby sehen, dann sagen sie, ah, guck mal hier
ein dunkelhäutiges Baby oder ein asiatisches Baby und ergänzen das um die Herkunft, das heißt eine,
KI, die dann aufgrund dieser Bildbeschreibung lernt.
Lernt direkt mit, ne? A hier, die Frau ist untergeben, ja? Oder ähm dass ein Baby ist weiß,
Und wenn es nicht weiß ist, dann ist es eben ein schwarzes Baby oder ein asiatisches Baby. Und ähm,
Er sagt dann eben das Datenmaterial, das dem Training äh neuronaler Netze zu Krone liegt,
kann eben genau diese rassistischen und sexistischen Stereotypen transportieren,
Und die dann unter Umständen von der Software repliziert werden, also genau das, was wir vor einigen Sendungen hier auch so festgehalten haben, dass,
Eine künstliche Intelligenz,
manifestiert das, was ihr beigebracht wurde, wenn man nicht dafür sorgt, dass sie äh andere Möglichkeiten hat und bei ähm.
In den in der Folge, wo wir das besprochen haben, haben wir irgendwie über sowas wie Kreditkreditvergabe oder solche Scherze gesprochen. Aber bei der komplexen Erkennung eines Bildes
Ist das natürlich durchaus äh Einkommen eine sehr viel komplexere künstliche Intelligenz als diese Basalen, die wir da im Beispiel genommen haben
klar, das heißt natürlich also was du tun musst ist,
möglichst diverse Datengrundlage haben und deine deine Bildbeschreibung eben nicht nur von
von von Weißen amerikanischen Männern da anliefern lassen. Also.
Was mich so ein bisschen wundert, weil diese McCanic getört hat wie vor allem so äh Arbeiter aus dem asiatischen Raum.
Ja, die Konten, die haben, glaube ich, gesagt, wir wollen nur Leute aus den USA. Also das war ganze Einschränkung. Sagst du jetzt Amerikaner haben?
Denn mit Cannical Turk geht übrigens auf den sogenannten Schachttürken zurück.
Ach ja, den Schachcomputer, ne? Ja.
Äh genau der erste, der gefakete Schachcomputer, der halt keiner war, sondern jeder Türke, der da halt in der Kiste saß und irgendwie.
Warum war der, warum Türke? Also er ist ja genau hier, ne? Schwarzes Baby, asiatisches Kind, mechanischer Türke, was? Also.
Na ja weil die Maschine da saß halt so ein Türke dahinter, also die war so eine so eine Figur dahinter
die halt aussah wie ein Türke aussah, also in einer klassischen, türkischen Tracht der damaligen Zeit so mit so einem roten Hut, mit dicker Krempe und,
also dann du blicktest sozusagen auf eine Figur eines Türken, der so den Eindruck machte als mechanisches System Schach zu spielen, auch wenn dann tatsächlich einfach ein kleiner Mann drin saß von dem glaube ich nicht klar ist, ob das,
glaube nicht.
Wahrscheinlich weißes Baby.
Ja, daraus darauf äh geht es auf jeden Fall zurück und Amazon hat das eben da für seine Sklavenplattform da irgendwie.
Genau. Na ja. Cyber Cyber Zigarette.
Was ist denn das.
Ja, also das ist echt es war wohl irgendwie die Tage, Weltnichtrauchertag.
Ach, echt?
Und dann fühlte sich das äh BSI äh bemüßigt äh irgendwie vor äh irgendwie eine Warnung rauszubringen und die Warnung.
Nee, ähm.
Ich ich suche gerade das mal hier, wohl wo er das findet. Ähm vielleicht Zigarette und haben gesagt, ja ähm.
Ich finde das jetzt gar nicht, ich habe nur die Artikel darüber.
Erzähl mal, ich so mal.
Das das BSI hat gesagt, ja hier übrigens Weltnichtrauchertag, ne, passt auf mit euren E-Zigaretten, die können euren Computer hacken. Und äh.
Ja, das ist äh grundsätzlich erstmal möglich. Ähm diese E-Zigaretten haben einen USB,
Anschluss, über den sie geladen werden.
Und ähm je nachdem wie jetzt diese E-Zigarette beschaffen ist, ich kenne mich mit E-Zigaretten nicht aus, äh die geneigten Dampfer, das sind ja keine Raucher, sondern Dampfer
Äh die dürfen sich äh gerne dann hier äh dürfen mich dann gerne
korrigieren, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, wird in der E-Zigarette etwas erhitzt, dazu befindet sich irgendwie ein kleiner äh Lipo-Akku da drin und der wird äh geladen über über die Schnittstelle, über die man eben heutzutage lädt und das ist USB
So, nun äh sagt das äh BSI, na ja, wenn du etwas über USB an deinen Computer steckst, kann es ja grundsätzlich,
Auch mit diesem Computer kommunizieren. Und sie warnten dann davor, ja, passt auf mit den E-Zigaretten, die hacken eure Computer.
So, dann hat äh heiße Online gefragt so ja schöne äh schöne Warnung, die sie da haben. Ähm gäb es, gibt es denn vielleicht auch tatsächlich dokumentierte Fälle von Schadsoftwareinfektionen über E-Zigaretten.
Oh ja.
Dann hat das BSI erstmal nicht beantwortet, geantwortet und gesagt.
Im Rahmen unseres Präventionsauftrages werden wir für wir für einen bewussten Umgang mit Informationstechnologie und Weisen in diesem Fall konkret auf das Sicherheitsrisiko hin, dass durch USB Ports entsteht.
Hierbei spielt es keine Rolle, ob ein Genuiner USB-Stick als Speichermedium ein Ladegerät für E-Zigaretten oder ein anderes über den USB-Pot anzuschließen, das Endgerät als Träger der Schadsoftware genutzt wird. Da möchte ich
wieder sprechen. Ähm und zwar,
Diese gesamte USB-Panik geht äh zurück auf ein äh auf eine Präsentation von äh.
Meinem ehemaligen Kollegen,
Jakob Lell, der das äh bei der Black Cat vorgeführt hat. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das auch dann nochmal beim,
Kongress vorgeführt hat und zwar hat Jakob ähm eine einen USB,
Gerät genommen. In dem Fall waren das USB-Sticks. Und wenn man sie jetzt so einen USB-Stick vorstellt, da ist halt eine Platine drin. Vorne ist eben, dann sind da die vier USB-Kontakte und die sind verbunden mit einem,
USB Controller. Das ist ein Chip, der äh USB spricht, also den Standard ähm USB,
beherrscht und diese Schnittstellenarbeit mit dem Computer verrichtet. Und dahinter sind dann noch ein paar andere Sachen drauf gelötet und dann eben die Speicherchips,
der Flashspeicher und dieser Controller macht eben äh, dass der USB-Stick an den Computer dran steckt, wird Strom kriegt und sagt, schönen guten Tag, ich bin ein USB-Gerät.
Und ich bin ein USB Gerät der Klasse,
Maß Storage Device, du kannst mit mir über das dir bekannte USB-Protokoll für Maß äh Storage Devices sprechen und dann werde ich der Daten speichern oder Daten liefern und jetzt geht's los.
Jetzt nimmst du dir eine Maus oder eine Tastatur und äh machst die auf, dann hast du da den gleichen Chip drauf mitunter,
Ähm der in dem Fall aber dann dem Computer sagt, hallo, ich bin ein USG Gerät der Klasse Human Interface Device. Ähm und ich bin also jetzt eine Tastatur und ich werde dir äh Tastenanschläge liefern,
und dann setze die Bitte um und was Jakob gelungen ist ist diesen, das war halt bei USB-Sticks, nachher wird's auch bei allem anderen gemacht ähm,
USB-Sticks um zu programmieren, dass sie, wenn sie mit dem Computer verbunden werden, zum Beispiel sagen, jo, hi.
USB Maßstorage, sie weiß, äh, Speicher und so weiter und wenn dann irgendwie eine Zeit lang keine ähm keine Verbindung mehr kommt,
Oder so, das kannst du also programmieren, wie du möchtest. Sagt der äh USB-Chip auf einmal. Ach so, äh übrigens ähm,
der Maß des Maßstaubs Device ist jetzt weg oder es ist immer noch da, aber ich habe hier übrigens auch noch eine Tastatur, das ist ein Humanita Festivals und dann konntest du äh eben,
In dem Moment mit dem Computer arbeiten, als hättest du physikalischen Zugriff darauf und zum Beispiel Tastenkombinationen eingeben. Das Gängige war dann eben, was weiß ich, Staat, äh P äh,
A, also Startprogramme ausführen oder sowas und dann Kalkexe oder dann eben ein
Powershell Kommando, mit dem du dir einen Trojaner nachlegst und dann den den Rechner infizierst. Ähm, dieser
die Sachen, die du mit der Tastatur machst, wolltest du möglichst simpel und kurz halten, weil es unglaublich schwierig ist.
Oder unglaublich viel Feinabstimmung benötigt, diesen Angriff dann auch wirklich gangbar zu machen. Das nämlich wenn der Nutzer noch dransitzt, der dir nicht irgendwie aus Versehen
in dein Befehl reinfruchtet. Ähm, also der Batty-USB-Angriff war ein,
bin ich immer noch sehr beeindruckt von der technischen Finest und der Genialität dieser Idee. Aber es ist eben auch ein Angriff, der in der Praxis ähm.
Trotzdem er jetzt jahrelang bekannt ist und dann auch einige andere Forscher äh Open Source Varianten davon äh veröffentlicht haben. Ähm,
einfach in der freien Wildbahn ohne nennenswerte äh Signifikanz. Äh bisher wird aber auch,
bei jeder Gelegenheit wirklich von jedem äh äh von jedem vortragenden aus äh,
aus dem Hut gezaubert, gesagt, heute kann ein einfacher USB-Stick zur Cyberwaffe werden und äh wir müssen jetzt USB-Sticks verbieten in unserem Unternehmen und was nicht alles. Also es hat eine unglaubliche Panik äh ähm,
herbeigeführt, die ich dem tatsächlichen, der tatsächlichen Realität dieses Angriffs äh finde ich vernünftig angemessen,
halte.
Es gab dann noch weitere Überlegungen wie du dann zum Beispiel auch erkennen kannst anhand dessen wie dein Computer mit dem USB-Stick spricht,
ob du jetzt von gerade in ein Mac Linox oder äh Windows gesteckt wurdest und dann entsprechend halt das Infektionskommando von Linux ausrollst, das Infektionskommando für ein Windows, das Infektionskommando für Mac.
Also dieser Angriff funktioniert, aber ich weiß aus eigener hautnah Erfahrung, weil ich eben bei der Entwicklung daneben saß und denen auch,
in verschiedenen Anwendungsfällen dann mal zu Demonstrationszwecken umgesetzt habe,
oder eingesetzt habe, wie schwierig es tatsächlich ist, das zu machen.
Also da da steckt der Teufel im Detail und ich glaube das hat eben auch dafür dazu gesorgt hat dafür gesorgt dass es kein massenhaftes
Angriffsphänomen wurde, weil es eben immer noch einfachere und billigere Möglichkeiten gibt, viel mehr Leute äh zu infizieren. Das musste dann eben auch so so der kurze Einschub
das BSI eingestehen,
Und haben gesagt, ja, USB-Speichermedien sind derzeit nicht der Hauptangriffsvektor für Cyberkriminelle. Schon weil die Verteilung von Schadsoftware nicht die,
nicht in derselben Breite möglich ist
etwa durch den Versand von Spam Mails. Dennoch ist der USB-Ports angesichts immer mehr aus skurriler USB-Fähiger Geräte ein mögliches Einfallstor für Schadsoftware, auf das es zu achten gilt. Grundsätzlich bekannt,
ist die Angriffsmethode via USB spätestens seit zwanzig vierzehn, also hier der klare Bezug auf äh die Forschung äh von Jakob,
Ähm was ich mich frage ist.
Ob so eine USB-Zigarette, so eine Cyberzigarette oder wie die heißen, E-Zigarette überhaupt,
Ein USB-Controller haben, den ich hacken könnte oder umprogrammieren könnte. Weil ich nicht weiß, ob diese Dinger Logik haben. Ich glaube, es gibt Modelle, die man dann irgendwie auch umprogrammieren kann
wo man sagt, mach wärmer oder kälter oder irgendwie sowas, also mit Sicherheit.
Demnächst auch irgendwelche Töne ab, wenn man dran saugt.
Das noch? Kommen da auch vorne Seifenblasen raus.
Da muss man die da reinlassen. Also so ein, ja, so ein Kram kommt bestimmt. Also, dass die irgendwann nicht so sich zurückhalten können und da auch noch versuchen, irgendwie einen MP3-Player oder sonst irgendwas mit einzubauen, da das sehe ich äh klar kommen.
Der MP3 Player spielt dann so Nichtraucher, Hörbücher.
Ja, aber.
Also ich finde es einfach, also ich.
Bist du denn ich höre jetzt so ein bisschen raus, du bist der Meinung, dass der Angriff weg der USB keiner ist oder nur so unpopulär ist, dass da kein größeres Problem von ausgeht, weil man kann doch durchaus.
Er wird in seiner Bedeutung, er wird in seiner praktischen Bedeutung massiv überschätz.
Okay, aber es ist auch nicht so, dass du sagst, es geht nicht.
Also das kommt auf das Modell an. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es E-Zigaretten gibt, in denen.
Nein, mir geht's nicht um die E-Zigaretten, mir geht's um USB an sich.
Grundsätzlich geht das. Ja, natürlich, mit äh mit äh vielen USB-Geräten, die also Jakobsforschung basierte auf den
Controllern und die hast du auch in Webcams gefunden oder so. Ja, da konntest halt eine konntest du Bad USB mit einer Webcam machen oder Batt USB mit
mit äh Netzwerkadaptern oder du konntest auch andere Spielereien machen, zum Beispiel äh dass das Ding sagt, ich bin eine Tastatur, war ja nur so die erste,
die erste Idee bis.
Moment, wo man sagt, ich bin ein Internetkabel und ich habe hier ein Link, dann äh machst du ja im Prinzip so einen Internetport auf und.
Ich bin Internetkabel und ich habe hier ein äh ich habe hier einen lustigen Exploid, der auf deiner,
Kiste funktioniert. Da ist schon viel Musik drin, aber das ist halt wirklich schon auch ein äh sehr.
Ja, also das ist ein Angriff, den muss man halt können. Ja, da muss, den muss man ziemlich gut können, da muss man viel Ahnung haben und das ist, wie gesagt, eben nicht umsonst ähm aus der Forschungsgruppe ähm,
auch die weltweit am meisten rezipierte äh das weltweit am meist rezipierte Forschungsergebnis gewesen,
eben auch, also das war irgendwie in in Asien, weißt du, Szenarien irgendwie bist du unterwegs
guckst Zeitungen oder steht da irgendwie so, oh mein Gott, äh irgendwie Hacker haben USB unsicher gemacht.
Aber er wird eben in seiner praktischen äh Relevanz äh eben massiv überschätzt.
Trotzdem sind da so USB Ladekondome jetzt auch äh durchaus ähm Szene.
Ja, ja, es ist auch keine blöde Idee, ne? Also ähm äh so ein so ein nur Ladekabel zu haben.
Ja, also es gibt ja so Zwischenstecker, ich habe jetzt gerade keinen Namen parat, gibt's wahrscheinlich auch schon viele.
Ja, die halt nur die beiden. Ja, die haben aber, glaube ich, also.
Ja, die das so einfach ist es nicht, dass man jetzt nur die beiden Kabeln nimmt, weil du musst halt heutzutage gegenüber deinem Ladegerät auch schon kommunizieren, was,
du denn überhaupt und so und äh weil sonst kriegst du nicht genug Strom und dann lädt
schnell genug und so. Also man braucht sozusagen schon etwas, was so halbwegs intelligent ist und es gibt irgendwelche Open Source, halt, äh, Projekte, die das machen,
ich grad nicht benennen kann. Das ist schon noch ein Thema äh für die Zukunft und bei der Masse an Telefon, die an Flughäfen in USB-Ports gesteckt werden.
Das ist aber ein anderes Ding. Also ich meine, ich finde halt also.
Erstens klar, du steckst, du solltest dein Telefon nicht einfach irgendwo dranstehen. Du solltest auch nicht ähm aber dieses dieses Ding jetzt halt, also ich meine, wir reden hier von dem Bundesamt für Sicherheit, in der Informationste,
dass sich Herr, dass ich nicht schämt vor einem Risiko zu wanden, für das sie null Anhaltspunkt haben
einfach nur um irgendeine Scheiße zu reden zum Weltnichtrauchertag. Und das finde ich dann halt schon, da merkst du halt, wie mit diesem Thema umgegangen wird. Wenn du ein besonders schützenswertes Gerät hast, was weiß ich, ein besonders äh schützenswertes Android-Telefon mit dem äh ein Kryptofon oder sonstwas, ja. Natürlich empfiehlt sich das da ein Ladekondom äh zu haben, ja?
Ich weiß, kann aber jetzt auch keine Empfehlung aussprechen, welches
welches Ladekondom da jetzt wirklich brauchbar ist, weil die Billigsten eben einfach welche sind, wo zwei Kabel gespart wurden und du eben nur Plus und Minus von Volt hast und die laden dann dein Telefon erschreckend langsam auf, äh weil sie eben, weil diese ganzen Ladegeräte auch, die Logik haben und nicht einfach zwei Ampere draufgeben, sondern ich glaube, Standard nur.
Halbes.
Ja also da da steckt der Teufel im Detail, aber ich äh betrachte mit wirklich mit ähm mit.
Sehr viel Sorge, wenn das Bundesamt versichert in den Formationstech eine Technik, eine öffentliche Warnung rausgibt,
Vor allem Angriffsmuster, das ist in, für das es in der Form keinen öffentlichen äh öffentlich bekannten Beleg gibt.
Im in diesem konkreten Fall USB-Zigarette. Allgemein grundsätzlich ja da ist zu Vorsicht geraten,
wenn ihr entweder an irgendwelchen Holes seid, also irgendwie so hey hier gibt's ja am Flughafen überall, der Lade hier, der Telefon kostenlos. Ja, wahrscheinlich, so, als wenn ich keine Powerbank dabei hätte, mit der ich das selber machen kann
oder eben mein eigenes Ladegerät, was ich auch an eure zweihundertdreißig Volt stecken kann. Also da da ist natürlich zu zu Vorsicht geraten, aber du brauchst eben natürlich,
in der Regel gerade, wenn du so ein Telefon hacken willst, dann auch noch irgendwie ein Exploid oder du musst so blöd sein, dass du das ADB noch anders auf deinem Android ähm also.
Ich finde nur diese Meldung des BSI äußerst unser.
Ist übertrieben, aber grundsätzlich.
Der eben aus dem aus dem Team kommt, der diesen, der diese, der diese Panik, äh, beabsichtigt oder nicht, äh, in die Welt gesetzt hat.
Ihr wart schuld, ja ihr habt die Ämter in äh Panik versetzt.
Also insgesamt wird dieses Bad. Nicht so, dass ich sehe schon.
Jetzt beschönigst du das, ich sehe schon, lade, Ladeschränke, die hinten offen sind und wo die Telefone gleich rausgenommen werden.
Türken die hecken dein Telefon.
Ja. Genau, die Schachttürken bedrohen unsere Telefone.
Also insgesamt wird diese diese USB-Geschichte noch ein bisschen heißer gekocht äh äh wurde wird die heißer gegessen? Ne, heißer gekocht als gegessen. Ähm
viel einfacher ist tatsächlich oder viel, viel klassischer ist übrigens eigentlich der Angriff, dass du so ein ähm so ein USB-Stick äh verlierst in Anführungszeichen, ne, weil irgendein Unternehmen auf,
auf dem Parkplatz und äh dann hast du halt irgendwie so eine Worddatei drauf an den ehrlichen Finderpunkt Rock Punkt Excel und damit kommst du holst du auch jede Büchse, ne? Also das ist irgendwie USB-Sticks, die verloren werden
immer von den Leuten aufgehoben und am Computer gesteck,
ne, dass da und dann wird natürlich geguckt, was da für Dateien drauf sind und wenn er draufsteht, bitte lesen oder so. Äh da da machst du es sehr viel einfacher, als das jetzt wirklich so eine Bad USB,
Implementierung machst und dafür sorgst, dass die auf deinem Zielsystem stabil funktioniert. Da ist die Schwierigkeit. Bett hospi selber ist nicht so schwer,
aber dass das die haben Angriffsfolge Tastenfolge oder Netzwerkangriffe, was auch immer du da machst, ähm stabil funktioniert. Da haben wir äh doch durchaus immer mal wieder Schwierigkeiten gehabt.
Blinde Kuh mit dem Baseballschläger sozusagen. So. Hast zwar ein starkes starke Waffe in der Hand, aber du weißt nicht so richtig, worauf du eindrischt.
Ja, du, also Basewatcher gar nicht so sehr, aber du musst halt irgendwie, wenn der Nutzer halt irgendwie ein anderes Fenster aktiviert, dann tipp deine Taste, du hast eben kein Feedback, du musst diesen Rechner blind bedienen.
Ich sage ja, blinde Kuh beim Baseballschläger. Also du weißt halt nicht auf was du eindrischt. So, triffst halt auf irgendwas ein, aber du weißt halt nicht.
Also du willst ja im.
Rückmeldungen kriegst oder ob du da nicht die ganze Zeit auf Sandsäcke draufhaust.
Wenn es dir hilft, dann ist das von mir aus eine blinde Kugel, Baseballschläger. Ich würde es eher sagen, so äh du musst den Baseballschläger erstmal finden.
Ja
Das ist erst, also so kaum nicht mehr da eher bei vor. Aber egal.
Auf jeden Fall blinde Kuh.
Das ist unseriös
Das BSI ist unseriös und äh kauft euch Cyber-Cyber-Zigaretten und heckt euch äh gegenseitig, damit das BSI irgendwann, damit das BSI wenigstens sagen kann, äh wir haben hier äh nicht nur Visionen gehabt, sondern waren auch äh visionär
mit dieser Warnung.
Genau, seid mal seid mal, seid mal ein bisschen seriöser, so wie Berlin. Hast du schon gehört? Berlin äh Berlin hat jetzt schnelles WLAN in Berlin. Ach nee.
Nee, wir hätten fast WLAN gehabt.
Fast fast nicht fast, fast fast WLAN,
Nee, wir haben jetzt, äh, nee, es wird alles gut. Äh, WLAN,
City-WLAN, wir haben's immer gewollt, ja, man macht einen Wasserhahn auf und die Bits kommen raus, gepurzelt. So haben wir das immer äh gewollt. Nach vielen Jahren hat Berlin jetzt reagiert.
Und hat zwei Access-Points in die Stadt gestellt.
Pariser Platz alles wunderbar ausleuchten wie die Startup-Bude, die dieses WLAN jetzt für die Stadt Berlin in Betrieb genommen hat, äh, behauptet hat. Das wäre total.
2-WLAN-Stationen strahlenden Platz perfekt aus.
Perfekt.
Der Pariser Platz ist, sagen wir, viermal so groß wie der Republikahof. Mhm. Ne, ungefähr oder zweimal, viermal. Pariser Platz ist schon.
Weiß nicht, ob das jetzt eine Größenordnung ist, mit der jeder was anfangen kann, die meisten kennen wahrscheinlich eigentlich eher den Pariser Platz, aber.
Aber ich will mal sagen so auf dem Republikahof,
würde ich jetzt vorsichtig schätzen, dass der ich weiß es nicht genau, aber ich würde davon ausgehen, dass der Clemens da bei so einer Republik hat zwischen vier und zwölf.
Access Points aufhängt für irgendwie diese Anzahl Leute, die sich da befinden. Nee, wäre jetzt so meine vorsichtige Schätzung.
Ja gut, wie viele Leute sich da befinden, ist ja egal. Die Frage ist, wie viele wollen dieses WLAN benutzen und wenn da halt auf einmal ganz viele Leute dieses WLAN benutzen, erscheint mir zwei, ähm also einerseits ist es ein bisschen unklug, weil sagen wir mal, da ist jetzt irgendwie so ein Event
Da ist ja ab und zu mal ein Event, oder?
Ab und zu ist da mal einer.
Da spricht dann mal ein amerikanischer Staatspräsident oder irgendwelche anderen unwichtigen Leute reden da oder irgendwelche Bands spielen da oder es wird Silvester gefeiert oder.
Viertel Million auf den einen Film.
Der Tag der Deutschen Einheit so, ne? Genau, also da liegen da schon mal so Love Brate, wollte ich jetzt nicht gerade rausholen, die ist ja schon durch.
Aber CSD, keine Ahnung, irgendwas ist da halt. Auf jeden Fall, dass da mal ein paar hundert oder vielleicht auch mal ein paar tausend Leute sich äh aufhalten soll ja schon mal vorgekommen sein,
Aber vermutlich gehen sie nicht unbedingt davon aus, dass so viele Leute das haben. Also zwei Exesspoint.
Das schränkt schon mal so ein bisschen die Zahl der Nutzer äh ein, aber vor allem ähm,
perfekt ausleuchten, heißt wahrscheinlich, sie haben irgendwie richtig schön äh aufgedreht, ihre Antennchen, die dann wirklich überall reinstrahlen und sich dann wahrscheinlich im Zweifelsfall auch noch wunderbar gegenseitig in die Quere kommen. Also.
Also was passiert die die machen den Launch? Stellen sich dann da in den äh hat geregnet, war am Mittwoch. Stellen sie sich ihren Regen mit so einem roten Notausschalter.
Das ist sehr schön gesagt, den Tod aus.
Ist doch ein Notaussch.
Ja, den hatten sie, äh ja, es ist überhaupt lustig, dass solche solche äh bekloppten Großprojekte eigentlich immer mit Notausscheitern in Betrieb genommen werden. Das ist eigentlich sehr Onest. Ja?
Ihr die machen, wir rücken den Notausschalter und wundern sich, dass ein WLAN nicht mehr geht.
Ja, bis eben ging's noch, warum haben sie denn diesen Schalter gedrück.
Entstanden da im Regen, haben wir auf diesen Schalter gedrückt und haben dann gesagt, ja aber oben ging's noch. Gerade hatte ich hier noch ordentlich elf Mbit. Als einziger Nutzer, der das vor dem offiziellen
Also vor dem Drucken des Notausstaters äh probiert hat über diese zwei Hotspots am Pariser Platz ins Internet zu kommen, hat er elf M mitbekommen. Ähm und,
Aber machen das Ding an, sagen so, jetzt geht hier das Internet, denn da ist irgendwie so ein äh ein Bild mit der wunderschönen Unterschrift und ich denke, das ist schon,
Das ist äh eine valide Bildunterschrift, da wird die künstliche Intelligenz keines Serotypen lernen, denn da steht ein Infopavillon, keine Touristen und kein WLAN.
Ja, haben das Ding halt irgendwie.
Nee, es ging ja was. Die Werbung kam.
Genau, denn es gab nur kein Internet, aber die Werbung kam trotzdem.
Was schon mal ganz interessant ist. Das heißt, sie haben's zumindest schon mal so ein bisschen ihr eigenes Data-Center äh geschafft oder vielleicht haben sie auch bei ihren Excess Points dieses Video direkt hinterlegt, damit auf jeden Fall schon mal die Werbung abgespielt wird, wenn auch kein Netz kommt
und es gab dann irgendwie kein zuverlässiges Netz. Was er sich schon mal wirklich.
Erstaunlich ist. Also wenn man noch nicht mal so eine mega gestageten Event, wo wirklich keine Fremdnutzer äh am Start sein,
also wahrscheinlich nicht so viele da sein würden und da irgendwie nicht gebacken bekommt.
Ja und dann äh haben sie jetzt irgendwie so eine so eine Webseite veröffentlicht, wo sie irgendwie eintragen äh wo es die, wo sie überall Hotspots hätten,
ne. Auch sehr gelungen und ich kriege dann am Mittwoch irgendwie ähm
sopanische Meldung von Alexander Sander, der sagt, Alter, hier ist irgendwie die BZ, die fragen nach dem Hotspot, den wir irgendwie hätten und ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wovon die reden. Denn ähm.
Die hatten dieses Unternehmen hatte irgendwie ein digitales Gesellschaft geschrieben. Jo, ey, voll geil hier, wir haben Hotspots und so, ihr kriegt ein
kostenlosen Hotspot, schicken wir euch und so, Volker Halb wir fern warten die Geräte über die Cloud, ihr müsst euch um nichts kümmern, müsst ihr nur aufstellen, ja?
Und da habe ich dann geantwortet, ja, schicke mal einen rüber. Lass mal gucken.
Und? Hast schon einen bekommen?
Nein, aber wir waren auf diese äh digitale Gesellschaft war jetzt dank meiner Mail äh auf dieser Karte,
Und äh dann waren irgendwie auf Twitter die Leute irgendwie so was, wie so, was habt ihr denn da irgendwie Free Wifi Berlin oder so und
dann kriegt halt digitale Gesellschaft Presseanfragen, ob das WLAN bei ihnen funktionieren würde
Und da ich jetzt irgendwie kein Bad Bescheid gesagt hatte, sagte Alexander dann so, ja, nee, dort federn, bei uns funktioniert, ja, aber wieso was ist denn los, warum? Warum fragen sie uns? Also ähm,
noch dazu haben sie halt jetzt diese Karte gelauncht, die irgendwie beeindruckend aussehen soll und haben da offenbar lauter Orte drauf,
an den es überhaupt noch gar kein, gar keine WLAN stand Standorte gibt.
Wieso? Also was.
Wieso sie das getan haben, weiß ich nicht.
Nein nein, was lässt sich glauben, dass es da gar keine gibt, obwohl da.
Weil ich eben die Erfahrung gemacht habe, dass äh wir da äh mit
digitalen Gesellschaft, äh das Büro der digitalen Gesellschaft verzeichnet war, das war einfach nur die Lieferadresse, die ich denen angegeben habe. Ihr habt den überhaupt nicht
gesagt, dass ich diesen Hotspot aufstellen möchte, geschweige denn, dass ich den in in der Singerstraße aufstellen wollen würde
trotzdem haben die dann so am Launch gesagt, ja hier und da äh ist auch irgendwie einer bei bei der digitalen Gesellschaft oder sowas, ne.
Aber das steht jetzt nicht, hier sehe ich keinen Pin.
Ja der an der Alexander hat den dann äh die dann auf den kleinen Fehler hingewiesen oder die zwei kleinen Fehler.
Verstehe. Verstehe, ja das ist halt.
So und wenn man sich einloggt, kriegt man Werbevideo von Audible oder was.
So hieß es in dem Artikel, ich habe das nicht selber nachvollziehen können, weil äh hier in der Mittebene gibt's ja noch kein Free Wifi Berlin, also zumindest nicht von Pre-Wifi-Berlin.
Ein Witz, ey.
Find's auch geil. Also ich meine.
Wie viele Jahre war das sechs Jahre lang, war das jetzt angekündigt, dass wir hier freies WLAN bekommen, oder? Das Projekt war doch auch x mal ausgeschrieben, da hatten doch die die Freifunke auch gesagt, so freies WLAN-Jahr, können wir machen, gib her, so. Wir wissen, wie das geht.
Bis Ende zwanzig siebzehn soll das Netz auf zweitausend Access Points anwachsen.
Ja, vor allem wir wissen ja alle, sowas geht ja nur, wenn's da auch einen Sponsor gibt. So,
Und jetzt hast du da halt Captiv Portal und tralala und dann musste der erstmal bekloppte äh Orderbewerbung anschauen
und trau mich gar nicht auch nur diese URL von dieser Karte ich meine das ist einfach das ist einfach so ein Armutszeugnis. Wenn Berlin das macht.
Was sie ja gerne tun können, ja? Dann hat die URL zu lauten Berlin DE Slash Wifi oder WiFi Berlin DE oder keine Ahnung, irgendwas mit Bezug zu dieser Stadt,
Und dann hat es eben auch nicht so als Werbeportal zu laufen. Ja, jetzt macht sozusagen die Stadt Werbung für dieses Unternehmen.
Und ich meine mal ehrlich, die paar Excess Poinster aufzubauen. Das ist doch lächerlich.
Ja, dass es doch einfach lächerlich.
Und wenn ich das richtig sehe, also es gibt das,
Also es gibt ein Captiv Pollöl und das ist dann hier, also ich gucke mir hier diese Bilder durch, die da ähm Tagesspiegelautor hier ähm in den Artikel geladen hat,
Da gibt's dann irgendwie ein Captif Portal, das ist Hörbücher Minus Blog Punkt DE, Free Wifer Berlin anmelden,
abbrechen, das heißt diese Werbung, die da kommt ähm,
Die haben also einen Captain Portl mit Werbung statt Anmeldung, ne? Also das das entnehme ich hier diesen,
Beschreibung und diesem Screenshot, ja geil,
Ja geil, weißt du? Und oben steht Berlin dran und dann irgendwie Audible, also hätten die das, wo hätten die das einfach mal mit den Freifunkern in Ruhe gemacht? Das wäre einfach, der hätte einfach funktioniert und wäre schön gewesen, aber selbstverständlich,
Lorenschnitt, ja, dieses dieses Ding mit dem Notausschalter und es funktioniert nicht.
So geht's nicht.
Auch Schodrowski irgendein was weiß ich wer auch immer das ist ähm,
Ach so, der Senat, der stellvertretende Senatssprecher Bernhard Schodrowski kam auch während des Pressetermins äh nicht in dieses Netz. Das lege aber vielleicht an seinem iPhone, sagte er zögerlich. Bei den anderen hätte es eigentlich immer geklappt,
Ah, wie peinlich.
Aber wie peinlich. Experten am Werk. Das ist also das ist wirklich peinlich und dass man auch nicht mal die Größe hat äh da einfach sich.
Und hier diese hundert, diese hundert Standorte, die sie jetzt bekannt gegeben haben, ja, sollen spätestens zum EM-Start am zehnten Juni in Betrieb gehen,
bin ich mal gespannt, weißt du? Also, digitale Gesellschaft hat noch kein Paket bekommen. Äh ist auf dieser war auf dieser Karte verzeich.
Oh, war ja.
Also was für Flach.
Also ich bin wirklich, ich bin wirklich, ich wäre sehr, sehr überrascht, wenn da irgendwas bei rauskommt, was deutlich über heiße Luft hinausgeht.
Ähm wäre ich auch sehr überrascht und ich finde das auch irgendwie extrem amüsant, dass sie die dass sie also wer an was für Vereine, die sich hier gewendet haben, ne. Der Seniorenschachclub Steglitz,
ist gekennzeichnet als Indoor Free Wifi Berlin. Äh wenn du dann irgendwie hast.
Das sind doch diese Schachteln. Die geben nur vor, dass da Internet ist.
Und Outdoorplätze gibt's in der Christian Morgenstern-Grundschule in Spandau. Und jetzt frage ich mich, ob ihr was irgendwie.
Jetzt reiten die ganzen Touristen dann sozusagen auf dem Pausenhof von der Grundschule ein. Geil, endlich, endlich Walfi.
Und dieses Wifi wird in der Pause sicherlich nicht funktionieren.
Ja, kann ja auch von ausgehen. Ich bin mal gespannt, weißt du, wenn du irgendwie für einen Pariser Platz äh zwei Excess Points brauchst,
äh rechnen sie bitte aus, wie viel brauchen sie für einen Schulhof, ähm der Christian Morgenschern Grundschule in in Spandau, also ein Quatsch. Und ich bin echt mal gespannt, was die da noch so für ein Bedingungswerk dazu schicken,
weil ihr offenbar davon ausgehen, dass sie ihr diesen dämlichen Hotspot bei den Leuten droppen, die den in Strom stecken und die die Unterhaltung dieses Gerätes auch noch irgendwie äh den Betrieb dieses Gerätes dann da auch noch über ihre Stromrechnung äh bezahlen, ne.
Ja, wo wo kommt denn vor allem die die Verbindung zum zum Netz her.
Ja, muss sein, ganz einfach stecken sie es bitte in ihren WLAN-Router. Ich kann mal ganz kurz gucken, ich habe die Million ihr selbstverständlich, was denkst du denn.
Ach man soll jetzt selber denen auch noch sozusagen die Bandbreite geben.
Der einzige, der einzige Unterschied ist, dass es sozusagen ein kostenloser Exesspoint ist, den man wahrscheinlich sowieso schon hat, das heißt, man baut sich nochmal ein konkurrierendes WLAN zu seinem eigenen auf.
Also die Mail war folgend, ich,
weil sie da predigt doch jetzt hier öffentlich zitieren können, haben hier eine Mail geschrieben, oder? Äh es sind nur noch wenige Geräte für das kostenlose freie Berliner Indoor-WLAN verfügbar. Ihr Standort kann ein solches Gerät von uns für die Gäste vor Ort,
kostenfrei bekommen. Bitte entnehmen sie Einzelheiten diesen Link WWW Berlin DE ähm,
wichtig, wer zuerst kommt, malt zuerst, daher entscheiden sie sich bitte schnell. Schieben sie die Entscheidung nicht auf. Voraussetzung, eine Internetverbindung,
mit mindestens sechs Mbit Bandbreite. Das Gerät wird Plug and Play am örtlichen Router per Cut Kabel angeschlossen.
Cut Kabel. Katzenkabel.
Ja, ich glaube, Internetkabel meint er wahrscheinlich, dass WLAN beinhaltet Jugendschutzfilter und Ruhezeiten. Die Geräte werden per Cloud ferngewartet.
Bitte informieren sie unsere Nürnberger Zentrale, wenn sie teilhaben wollen, bitte antworten sie alternativ auf dieses Gerät geht ihnen umgehend per Paketpost zu, habe ich mich natürlich nicht zweimal bitten lassen.
Gesagt, bitte einmal äh einmal Gerät.
Hallo, hier haben wir ein Gerät, was wir von außen.
Hier haben wir ein Gerät. Hier haben wir ein Gerät.
Ansteuern in ihrem eigenen Heimnetz.
Hier haben wir ein Gerät mit mit Wartung über Cloud, Jugendschutz, Filter und Ruhezeiten. Ja, also na ja, ich will da jetzt nicht weiter, ich will das Gerät ja auch noch haben. Insofern also ich habe da ja tatsächlich äh.
Jetzt führen wir das einfach nochmal richtig gut.
Ich habe da auf jeden Fall einen Anwendungszweck für das Gerät und äh hoffe halt, dass äh digitale Gesellschaft das dann bald bekommt.
Dann gucken wir mal.
Morone.
Es sind traurig.
Es wird traurig. Es ist so traurig. Ah, läuft's.
Die Berliner Senatskanzlei fördert das Projekt mit einhundertsiebzigtausend Euro. Dieses WLAN-Ding.
Die Werbung von Audible wird mit Geld gefördert.
Ich werde wahnsinnig.
Am Mittwoch erster sechster kommen die ersten einhundert von insgesamt sechshundertfünfzig Access Points. Zeitgleich im Betrieb, Berliner, in Berlin, bis Ende.
Bezahlen, was man die.
Dreihundertfünfundzwanzig Indoor und dreihundertfünfundzwanzig Outdoor-Excesspoints. Die technische Umsetzung übernimmt die
ABL Social Fideration GmbH
europäischer Marktführer im Bereich Managed Hotspot Services verwendet werden hochmoderne, speziell für den Einsatz im Außenbereich sowie in Umgebungen mit hoher Funkdichte entwickelte Geräte. Content Partner der ABL Social Figuration GmbH ist das Berliner Unternehmen
Audible, führende Anbieter digitaler Audioinhalte
dass das Projekt finanziell unterstützt, sowie eine Interviewreihe typisch Berlin produziert hat, die zu Beginn der WLAN-Nutzung zu hören ist.
Auch noch Podcast ausschla.
Zwangszwangswerbung, ja. Zwangspodcasts ähm im
im hochmodernen Gratis-WLAN und äh die Berliner Senatskanzlei fördert die Scheiße mit einhundertsiebzigtausend Euro, ich will mein Geld zurück.
Und wir machen hier Podcasts, weißt du?
Wir könnten den irgendwie kaputtes WLAN andrehen, was wo was bei anderen Leuten in die Bude schrauben.
Äh und noch reich werden dabei.
Hundertsiebzigtausend Euro überlegt mal bitte, für sechshundertfünfzig Excess Points.
Ja, das sind zweihundertsechsundzwanzig Euro. Geil.
Ich komm auf eine höhere Zahl.
Was? Hundert, hundertsiebzigtausend Euro.
Bis sechshundertfünfzig nicht siebenhundert in der äh.
Sechshundertfünfzig. Ja. Ah ja, also ich hab siebenhundertf.
Ja, zweihundertsechzig, zweihunderteinundsechzig, zweihundertsechzig Euro.
Geil.
Für zweihunderteinundsechzig Euro habe ich auf jeden Fall einen performanten Hotspot. Kann ich bereitstellen. Der funktioniert dann aber auch.
Ja. Der funktioniert. Kriegst du eine schöne Fritzbox für.
Wo ist denn das Geld hin.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das einfach im Fall wir wissen, die werden da keine Fritzboxen austeilen, sondern sie werden irgendwelche.
Spezial. Genau. Taiwan Scheiße sein, die irgendwie wahrscheinlich gut abhängen.
Feuer fängt und dafür brauchen die das Geld, um dann die abgebrannten Häuser irgendwie zu bezahlen.
Oh Gott, ey Leute, echt jahrelang. Unsere Stadt.
Warte. Was machen mit unserer Stadt, ey? Wir wollen hier in Ruhe leben.
Deswegen.
Boah, ist unglaub.
Macht.
Bis die Scheiße läuft, gibt's dann irgendwie fünf G und keine Sorge, wenn auf WLAN. Ah okay. Gut, ähm,
Jene äh wenigen Hörer und Hörerinnen, die nicht in Berlin wohnen, für die das Thema, über das wir jetzt eine halbe Stunde gesprochen haben, keinerlei Signifikanz hat, kommt doch einfach mal nach Berlin und äh guckt euch das Theater an,
Wir haben jetzt auch gratis WLAN.
Na ja gut. So, gehen wir auf die Demo.
Geh mal auf eine Demo. Ja, machen wir. Wo denn.
Bin. Ich gehe auf Demo. Demo. Ja, ich gehe.
Timo? In dem in Wien.
Ja, ich bin da. Werde da sein. Ach klar. Wenn da so Demo ist, zum Thema Netzpolitik.
Worum.
Ist das Lokboot, Testpolitik vor Ort.
Vor Ort. Am dritten Juni bis morgen.
Mhm. Gucken, dass die Sendungsteil noch rauskriegt.
Siebzehn Uhr dreißig äh Demo für Netzneutralität in Wien in der Mariahilferstraße, Ecke Naubaugasse.
Geschrieben?
Ich habe das geschrieben.
Weiß ich nicht, aber AK Vorrat AT Slash Note Slash eins fünf sieben, äh da ja unsere Hörerschaft immer sofort nach Veröffentlichung äh hört äh könnt ihr es also noch schaffen.
Genau. Doktor Bundespolitikhörer dürfen auch äh mal winken,
Falls ihr mich irgendwo rumstehen seht, aber ich werde tatsächlich morgen in Wien sein, aus anderen Gründen und ja, dementsprechend werde ich mir das nicht nehmen lassen, mal mir das äh Treiben anzuschauen,
Hintergrund ist das ja im Rahmen der Netzneutralität auch treffend in Wien stattfinden und.
Dementsprechend gibt es dann auch eine passende Demonstration dazu.
Und das bringt uns an das Ende der Sendung.
Und am Ende der Sendung kommt immer der Dank dieses Mal an Sebastian Thorsten Stefan und Muhn.
Und alle anderen Spender. Ja, Ninos, ich glaube, das war's für diese Woche.
Das war's für diese Woche und wir hören uns vielleicht in der nächsten.
Genau, bis bald.
Bis bald, ciao ciao.